teil darunter fall darunter du [ __ ]
fall du doch runter alter ist er tot
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer runde war
oh training eigentlich sollte heute ein
video zusammen mit cap kommen allerdings
ist bei mir alles asynchron mit der face
cam und dem ton und alles mögliche das
wollte ich auch ehrlich gesagt nicht
antun hef und ich habe mich eigentlich
vor ein paar tagen getroffen haben so
eine runde irgendwie ein minigame
aufgenommen das zusammen gezuckt und
kurz war unsere taktik bei wago geredet
allerdings habe ich mir jetzt gedacht
hat dass bei mir echt totale scheiße
geworden ist total asynchron und alles
mögliche das wollte ich euch echt nicht
antun deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich
will das ganze jetzt nach der wenig so
viele sachen gesagt haben das kann ich
auch schnell nachholen ohne dass ich
jetzt noch abends um halb zwölf am
freitag aus dem bett holen oder so ok
ich weiß nicht ob ich gerade normale
survival oder krieg survival games weil
wir nicht alle in der mitte starten das
ist gerade ein bisschen komisch und ich
brauche definitiv safe irgendwie ein
schwert oder so jetzt fällt es immer
recht schwer vernünftig beim thema zu
bleiben wenn ich neben beispiele ich
wollte auch erst im hintergrund noch
runde packen das wollten kämpfen die ich
auch eigentlich machen allerdings sehr
geil vier brode super ich habe ein
schwer du kommt er ihr folgt die dicke
da na ja jedenfalls wollte ich während
dieses videos du kleiner pizza hot pot
der tenne heftige rüstung am start box
die beiden erst mal bitte boxee box
durch box tops durchboxte die beiden
sollen sich erst mal boxen auch falsche
richtung da hinten den ttc schon bei
wahr oder falsch ist und man noch mal
zwei holzschwerter ok 14 verbleibenden
spiele ich lauf hier wiederum ihr
letzter apfel übrigens während war o2
wird es mir nicht gestattet sein dass
ich darum schneide weil man natürlich
erkenntnis auswahl 1 man muss alles was
man auf dem server macht auch hochladen
damit niemand irgendwie sagen kann ja
ich war auf dem server ich war da gar
nicht drauf oder irgendwas schiiten oder
irgendetwas komisches anderes machen was
nicht erlaubt das heißt man muss alles
aufnehmen darf keine kap setzen ist ein
bisschen doof also natürlich ist es gut
die regel
allerdings da ich immer gern ein
bisschen dann bearbeiten bin und du ist
das für mich dann natürlich ein kleines
so
ein einstein schwer ich habe das gefühl
jemand hinter mir ich würde hier ein
bisschen bearbeiten aber es ist ganz gut
dass es nicht geht ich bin tot da kommt
einer von hinten wie pussy ist das denn
so ludwig sg war ich muss doch nicht ich
denn dann muss nicht in quick sg ich
muss in ganz normales hier ist so will
games ganz normal solo sg-team sg solo
es geht um gehe ich mal ihren solo es
gehe ganz normal sole 24 ore jedenfalls
wollte ich ein paar sachen sagen die ich
eigentlich mit cap sagen wollte es tut
mir echt leid ist jetzt nicht dabei ist
tut mir leid dass sie unsere aufnahme
hier gelöscht wir haben acht minuten
echt perfekt drüber geredet
alles gesagt was wir machen wollen und
zwar sage ich das noch mal ganz kurz
unkonzentriert gameplay und zwar sind
jetzt auch im richtigen zwei games have
und ich haben nämlich für den anfang die
taktik gedacht wir laufen was das zeug
hält wir können natürlich also am anfang
gibt zwei möglichkeiten es gibt ja 50
oder 50 bis 56 mitspieler so wie ich das
jetzt richtig gelesen hat in der conti
bonds und wenn wirklich viele davon in
die mitte laufen ist es in der mitte am
risikoreichsten das heißt in der mitte
wird es heftig zu gehen da wird richtig
chaos sein das heißt wir gehen entweder
risiko und nein ich hatte doch das
schwert ich hatte doch das schwert ich
hatte doch das schwert ich hatte doch
das schwert in der hand wie kann mir das
denn aus der hand geklaut werden also so
wie das jetzt gerade es wird es dann in
faro zwei nicht laufen sondern wir
werden erstmal laufen was das zeug hält
weil wir keine lust haben dass wir da
direkt am anfang irgendwie am verrecken
sind wenn wir dann in der mitte laufen
dann kann es natürlich sein dass wir in
der mitte ich werde direkt getötet
locker straße eigentlich diese mit der
hand boxer aber ich habe jetzt einfach
angst dass er das bei mir gleich macht
wenn er dann schwer drin am start hat
dann ist das aber groß malta die ju
nein ich bin dumm ich wollte das einfach
oder da baumelt irgendwas am start ist
total am blättern und blumen und
blablabla ok erstmal schön nicht hat
hier noch irgendwer vorbei kommt also
unsere taktik bei wird einfach sein am
anfang ist es entweder so dass wir in
die mitte laufen oder es kann oder wir
beide laufen halt einfach weg und das
war halt unsere entscheidung wo wir uns
zwischen entscheiden mussten entweder
weglaufen oder direkt am anfang in die
mitte und versuchen irgendwie der
steinzeit zu bekommen weil es gibt nur
einen stein schwert meine ich richtig
informiert zu sein und sonst liegen in
der mitte halt so was wie ein leder
harnisch oder
oder eine holzschwert oder irgendwie
noch holz spitzhacke oder so das sind
sachen wenn man wegläuft kann man sich
die innerhalb von einer minute selber
kraft indem man eben sollen so einen
baum irgendwie fällt oder sowas einfach
macht das geht eigentlich relativ
schnell deswegen haben wir uns gedacht
ok kommen wir entscheiden uns dafür dass
wir am anfang erstmal die post die
taktik nehmen wir laufen einfach
weggehen mit keinen konflikt und nur
wenn lediglich zwei leute hinter uns her
sind dass wir dann auch sprint nur mit
mit hüpfen und so und alles mögliche
da hatten wir echt so ein bisschen sieht
mir alles viel zu gefährlich auch wusste
so ein bisschen unsere taktik dass wir
es am anfang ruhig angehen und danach
wirklich also es gibt 15 minuten muss
man aufnehmen da gibt es neue regelungen
ich weiß nicht wie viel ich jetzt schon
sagen darf aber ok ich hab' ich gesagt
da gibt es eine neue regelung 15 minuten
damit das besser ist dass man nicht
irgendwie aus versehen überzieht und
alles mögliche und dann wird man echt
auch gekickt nach diesen 15 minuten und
die sache ist halt einfach dass ein
bisschen gefährlich außer vorne wieder
wenn dann immer diese auch guck mal hier
was wir hier noch alles für schöne
tschechien machen haben der bruder da
hinten hat einfach die die axt am start
da komme ich bestimmt nicht rein ich
komme da bestimmt nicht ran aber ich
hab' ich bin so dumm
auf einer skala von eins bis luca wie
dumm bin ich das ist ja so krass ich
werfe einfach meinen meine tranter weg
jetzt bin ich ja natürlich in der
zwickmühle
kommt er da hinten gesperrt der neiße
schwert am start was geht er mit ihm
alter eher leisen schwert am start wie
soll ich das denn schaffen mit meinem
gott weil ihr seht schon bahro 2 wird
lauf wenn freud mitlaufen beim einfach
mal ganz kurz in der lobby dass ich eben
unsere taktik noch ein bisschen sagen
kann und zwar werden wir am anfang
wirklich laufen was das zeug hält und
danach werden wir uns relativ gut darum
bemühen dass wir danach relativ zeitnah
zweite und dritte aufnahme schon an
start bringen wo wir uns darum bemühen
dass wir nett zu bekommen und so was wie
zuckerrohr so ausschlaggebende sachen
die man nicht braucht die nicht
unendlich vorhanden sind also ganz grob
zusammengefasst am anfang
niels bohr nebeneinander wir drehen uns
um die einrichtung hoffentlich da kommen
keine andere mit uns irgendwie mit und
wenn welche mit kommen dann werden wir
die versuchen abzuhalten dass die von
uns mit kommen dann erst mal chillen und
nicht direkt sterben sowie kämpft das in
war einst gemacht hat
sondern wirklich einfach nur dass wir da
ganz lässig dann und alles mögliche es
war schön und schön ist das richtige
wort in einem ersten video kuhmann baum
wenn ihr kev und mir also kräftig sind
in einem team wie heizen hashtag
concetto sehr schön werden ihr auch
jetzt kommt jetzt ist ja einer der heiß
kompakter und die halle und jetzt haben
sie wohl irgendwie gesehen nicht hupen
naja jedenfalls wenn ihr uns bei twitter
und dabei irgendwo anders wollt dann
könnt ihr uns auch während den aufnahmen
immer also ja geil wie kann man denn
bitte das ist nämlich auch die sache
wenn ich in die mitte laufen würde ich
könnte nie ich eine kiste und denken
meine augen ersten okay da sind sondern
es schon wieder das erste mac weil er in
solche leute den ganzen tag zocken
wilson haben ihrem aus fdp heißt es dpi
ich weiß garnicht zehn milliarden
eingestellt und und
ramsen sich da die items über ein po und
was lara ich hier überhaupt
die ziehen sich da einfach direkt die
items raus es ist echt so krank das
könnte ich einfach nie deswegen haben
wir halt beschlossen wir gehen am anfang
erstmal die nummern locker also erst mal
am anfang ein bisschen chillen ist echt
das richtige wort finde ich schön ist
echt ein tolles wort taktik die pussycat
taktik und danach wird ordentlich
gemetzelt meine lieben freunde ist
hektisch was drin neda ist nichts drin
ich gucke auch schon ganz da bin ich
irgendwelche leute sind die mir etwas
böses wollen mal eine art schon mal
vielversprechend aus hier ist einfach so
eine riesige wendeltreppe nach oben
lauft die treppe hoch also das einfach
so zu unserer zu unserer taktik so ein
bisschen das ist keine richtige taktik
jetzt wo wir sagen okay ja wir machen
hier mit dem wort [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] von sagen jetzt
nicht wirklich ja das ist hier mit dem
fall noch unter fall darunter du [ __ ]
fall du darunter alter ja ja ist er tot
ist tot
erst holt okay ich habe ihn nicht
getötet das hätte ich jetzt nicht
gedacht dass ich ihn da runterschubsen
kann hatte ich lauf hier oben so
komplett ohne items nur mitzureisen helm
einfach und jetzt schob sich ihnen hier
einfach total glücklich einfach runter
und er hatte sogar richtig geile sachen
am start alter der tiere so eine coole
hose dann hat er hier noch so ein paar
essens sachen ich glaube dass es eine
gruppe von arbeitern einer kommt also
was ich sagen wollte wir haben keine
taktik wo wir sagen okay comcast du mit
dem bogen und ich mit der angel und
andere weisen ob das erlaubt ist aber
unterseite mit einer seite mit schwert
und dies und das und anderes
das aber wir haben halt wirklich gesagt
okay am anfang jetzt mal chillen die
erste folge weglaufen versuchen zu
überleben und danach uns organisieren
und danach erstmal gucken die sache ist
halt auch dass die hat er bestimmt schon
gut hat der noch nicht genug awards 0
gut ich habe einfach nur hosen am start
ich habe echt nur holten weil so das ist
echt so ein bisschen ich glaube das wird
auch bei mir
barroso ein bisschen bestimmen und zwar
einfach dieses mit so ein bisschen grips
kämpfen nicht so einfach drauf und alles
mögliche sondern wirklich so ja okay ich
lots immer runter und versucht den
darunter zu schubsen
sowas mehr in die richtung ich hoffe
zumindest dass es so wird was ist das
denn jetzt hier von rauhut jetzt einfach
nichts hier ist einfach nichts ja
einfach nichts ich hoffe natürlich dass
war gut endet für kev und mich also
unser ziel ist es unter die zehn letzten
teams zu kommen das heißt unter die top
20 spieler was schon sehr sehr hoch
gegriffen ist das ganze projekt wissen
wir nicht wie lange das das geht in etwa
das ist natürlich immer offen gestellt
wenn da als 1000 kämpfe gibt dann ganz
natürlich länger gehen es gibt aber
freunde das kann ja schon mal sagen
jetzt gibt neue regelungen die das ganze
projekt so ein bisschen besser machen
sage ich mal einfach die das ganze so
ein bisschen spannender auch machen für
euch und ihr könnt natürlich wieder mit
uns interagieren wenn ihr dann natürlich
irgendwelche fragen habt zum projekt
oder irgendwelche themen über die
kämpfen ich während den aufnahmen
vielleicht reden sollen während wir dann
gerade alle gegner abschlachten oder
sowas oder irgendwie weiß ich irgendwas
wollt dann könnt ihr das einfach auf
twitter mit dem hashtag hash der capcom
schreiben und dann werden wir uns
bemühen dass wir da mit euch so ein
bisschen in kontakt treten interagieren
und den ein oder anderen kommentar und
tippt mit in die folge rein nehmen
guck mal wie chili ich hier ist einfach
so richtig viele sachen am start erst
mal hier schön alles anziehen bevor ihr
jetzt noch irgendwie kommt sind das
eisen auf eisen eisen alles eisen am
start ihr hier haben wir noch ein paar
trenk hier in amerika app welche
inhaltlichen bogen ich brauche bauen
bauen bauen bauen
ich brauche echten bogen ich habe 16
pfeile alter der radar zeigt man dass da
hinten der nächste spieler als ich mal
kurz das mit das aus wie kann ich
eigentlich zwei teams miteinander
austauschen im inventar oder irgendwie
so weiß dass irgend wer von euch ich
sehe das manchmal bei anderen youtuber
dass sie einfach etwas drücken und
tauschen sich so zwei teams aus aber ich
weiß nicht genau wie genau das
funktioniert ich glaube der rote pfeil
zeigt in die richtung vom spieler oder
bewegt sich dann ich weiß es nicht das
ist auch wieder so eine sache zeigt der
rote pfeil in die richtung von einem
spieler oder der der schwarze das ist
wieder so eine richtige luca frage oder
zeigt er etwa in die richtung von manuel
neuer
guck mal da hinten ist ein name dass
sein name dass ein name da sind zwei
leute da sind zwei leute ich schaue erst
mal sie die im team sind die im team der
eine wird verfolgt okay da wird verfolgt
ich werde jetzt versuchen der zweite
diamant axt aber ich glaube ich habe ein
bisschen bessere rüstung und natürlich
den besten skill ich werde jetzt erstmal
bisschen warten die box nicht gerade
erst mal aus maul und jetzt gehe ich
hier drauf und witz die witz so zu tode
gedroht
und jetzt der andere kommt der
andenstaat untersagt gelaufen ich habe
gerade ein bisschen angst der anderen
hin wo ist ihr anrennen ich hoffe
überhaupt betonen dass das ganze nicht
viel zu leise ist für euch erstmal hier
die schuhe anziehen ich habe angst er
könnte überall sein dieser typ der
könnte überall sein was sagte mein
kompass noch drei verbleibenden spieler
ich bin unter den top 3 also dass am
anfang war ich eine lebensrettende noch
zwei verbleibenden spieler nur noch ich
und ein anderer das am anfang war echt
eine lebensrettende aktion dass ich da
am anfang diesen typ darunter gekickt
hat das war so wichtig und ja meine
lieben freunde ich habe endlich einen
bogen am start und ich habe hier auch
brötchen ein bisschen was zu fressen und
alles mögliche wenn ich dieses match
gewinnen dann habe ich automatisch wahl
gewonnen es besteht sich jetzt mal eben
oder habe ich dann etwa manuel neuer
gewonnen ich weiß es nicht und das match
beginnt in jetzt ja
hey hey hey wo ist der andere typ zu typ
wusste er hat den unsichtbarkeit rang wo
ist diese andere typ wusste hin
hey was ist was soll das denn hat den
unsichtbarkeit trank oder oder was ist
hier los mit dem desaster und da kommt
der falcon crafter hier und zack und
frästeile und fritz pfeile und frisst de
und schritt und tritt barmen und frisst
und frisst und wieso treffen nicht die
gehen doch alle total auf ihnen wie sie
treffen nicht diese pfeile bahn junge
fritz pfeile bahn bruder fritz sie
frisst und jetzt gehen wir hier
natürlich in den nahkampf ein depp ist
ich hab ja ist er sie gays de sie und er
hat sogar noch er hatte einfach eine
diamant aber ich war ich gut ausgerüstet
mit den ganzen reisen sachen muss ich
schon sagen ich bin stolz auf mich ich
weiß meine pvp es gilt sie nicht die
besten ich denke auch nicht dass ich
ware gewinn werde wenn ich ware gewinnen
werde
wenn ich jeden von euch beiden
videotheken 1 ausgeben aber ich würde
mal sagen jetzt euch gefallen hat freut
mich über wert und tut mir nochmal freue
ich mich immer bewährt und freue mich
über deine bewertung wenn es euch
gefallen hat natürlich nur wenn es euch
nicht gefallen hat natürlich die daumen
nach unten drücken
wir haben so ein ähnliches video auch
auf kanal gedrehter könnte caps kanal
auschecken der findet ihr auch den
findet ihr auch wenn jeder wahre folge
in der zweiten zeit in der beschreibung
und sonst war's das erstmal mit den
informationen waro geht am haben schon
sehr viele gesagt was muss ich glaube am
die erste folge und dann sehen uns da
wieder tschüss